hello everyone this is Amir from audio
songs review I did a review of a cable
uh from a company called gr research uh
a few months ago and a company recently
posted a video responding to that and I
made a number of points and I thought
I'd do a video and address them
um in that video I wore a special shirt
from goes by now from NASA that says you
know Earth is not flat uh we've been up
there and we've seen it there isn't a
word that is because the company founder
Danny used to wear that t-shirt all the
time and say anybody that followed audio
science must believe that the Earth is
flat and it would wear this t-shirt
which made no sense uh thankfully he
doesn't do that anymore
anyway
um he produced this 40 minute video
and I originally wasn't going to respond
to it because there's hardly anything of
substance in his uh video but some of
the members asked that I respond to it
and I decided that I should go ahead and
do that and so I marked this for
entertainment I'm not sure that there is
a whole lot of uh you know technical
knowledge being imparted that certainly
not in his video but maybe get a few
things out of it and looks like I uh uh
couldn't spell my own name on top of
that so you could do this value of this
video anyway uh so let me just summarize
this cable this B24 cable it's a power
cable has been set to uh use it with
your Source components I used it for a
pre-amplifier
I'm just summarizing the issues that I
found was that it has no safety
certification uh you buy even a you know
one dollar power cable and it will have
UL or a CE certification there's none
here and that's a big major issue it's
got a poor design and it's got this
sleeve on it that as you try to plug it
in the sleeve slides forward and makes
you think that you actually plug it in
when you haven't and that is Complicated
by uh by the fact that the pins on this
out uh plug that he's got are too thick
the ground pin is too wide to fit even
in my industrial trip light uh
um power strip that I use and I had to
force it with such energy that this slid
forward and the company says this was
glued I don't know how you glue shrink
wrap with uh here or whatever is inside
of it either way I've seen and owned
premium power cables none of them have
this kind of you know hokey sleeve on
them
um uh on this thing are you uh knowing
that that would get pushback from him
and others on on uh was reviewing this
cable I did not lead with measurements
actually now uh LED with a null test of
music so I took music uh captured it
with a cheap thin long uh throw away a c
chord and then I captured it with this
cable and as you'll see and I'll review
again that there is no difference
between it too measurements proved the
same thing that the audio waveforms
coming out of the uh preamp that I was
testing did not change my IO one iota
there were two positives it did have
slightly lower resistance than the other
two premium cables and certainly from
the thin cable but the difference was
extremely minimal as far as the impact
it has and I'll get into that and I
measured that it is more immune to noise
um but I'll again explain why that's not
Material
if you watch the company's video he
makes a number of planes and but then he
also goes in the comments and
exaggerates some of those claims and
adds to him
um I'll be going through all of this
thing you could just sort of glance at
it but it's ambiguous what he's saying
half the time like he says noise is
reduced noise in what direction uh if no
is going into AC cable why do I care
about noise going into an AC cable for
example uh it's not a you know carrying
musical signal there's a noise going out
so not very precise and that you know
the any improvements in this cable makes
can't be measured and interestingly
enough he makes it a given that he makes
an audible difference therefore anything
that you say that would invalidate that
would say that what you're saying is
wrong so if you say uh you know look why
can't I measure this thing he says well
your measurements are wrong because I
know that there's audible difference so
if your measurement doesn't show it you
know the uh that's your problem not mine
which is kind of silly he also claims
when people ask them to do a blind test
in the comments he says oh I've passed
hundreds of them he's passed hundreds of
them but we don't have a single one of
them showing this power cable making a
difference and and important what
protocol is used in that blind test
so it starts off with saying I'll have
an agenda I told him in my comment and
that's kind of silly to make that point
you have an agenda you're selling a
cable and you're patting yourself on the
back that you're the expert and you have
Golden Ears and that you think you know
it it makes a difference like don't
bring your gender into this discussion
because you know you you have a serious
agenda on my part I showed the good with
the bad I didn't have to do that I could
have just ignored some of the good
things it does with noise reduction and
uh and uh lower resistance but I did and
the difference between two of us is that
you know I'm not here to make a living
off of this uh gig there are no ads for
this video there's no sponsorship
there's nothing on audio science review
either on this thing so
but put all that aside everything I do
you know people can replicate and and
confirm unlike his claims we can't you
know he says I hear the difference well
Greg we don't know how to confirm that
but with mine when I show null tests and
measurements everybody can confirm my
stuff and if I keep uh you know cooking
these things people will find out that
I'm cooking them and and helping out a
business uh literally speaking and this
thing so
um you know there's a big difference
there anyway
um first thing starts with hey you need
200 hour breaking how stupid of Amir to
to not do the 200 hour break and
um and my first answer to that is where
the 200 come from why isn't it 150 why
is it 180 300 500 where'd that number
come from it's a very specific number
which means it was measured if this
measure tells how it was measured how
did you determine that that 200 or
something magic happened uh or even
close to it why isn't it 50 hours or 10
hours uh nothing like that was provided
other than just declaring that you need
200 hours
um key thing to understand is that AC
cables don't carry your music so while
some people claim you know things happen
to your inner connection speaker cables
well none of that matters for a power
cable power cable just carries raw power
and it's pretty dirty coming out of your
wall and uh you know what are you doing
with with forming the you know the uh
insulator or whatever people are client
uh on this thing one big disappointment
for me personally was that he showed
what's inside the cable and it's this
just this thick rope and this jacket
which means 95 of what you think you're
buying is actually not wire the wire is
actually much thinner it's wrapped
around this this rope so you're paying
for a thick rope with some wire wrapped
around it uh on this thing so you can go
make your own then you know just advice
I'm broken and wrap the wire around it
with this jacket around it but it's very
typical of how everybody thinks they
should make all these companies sell
premium cables think the thicker the
better and it is people just intuitively
think y'all must be bigger better cable
so that you put a thick rope in the
middle anyway
um if this is required how come there
are people pricing the cable as soon as
they get to this that they sound
improving that somebody said that in the
comments why doesn't he complain and say
well you didn't break it in so what your
heart was invalid you got to let it go
for 200 hours what if 200 hours it gets
worse not better
and then finally if it needs 200 hours
you do it you're charging me 400 for
this cable you burn it in for a week
whatever needs to happen you do it if
you need to run over with the tank run
over with the tank don't make it my
problem to go do this uh you know I
expect you to sell me what you advertise
to be which is it sounds great so uh you
know you should do that
okay
um he then claims the only bit of
technical that it brings to this 40
minute video is this test that actually
turned out to be incomplete he says you
can't null noise but my null test wasn't
the purpose wasn't to show that noise
had changed although if it had you could
have seen that but that the music itself
had not changed a lot of people get
these things because say the base is
tighter the sound stays wider deeper for
all those things to happen the musical
signal needs to change the way we detect
depth is based on sound intensity and
timing difference between what our two
ears pick up and that for the musical
content has to change for the two years
to hear some different and have a
perception of Sound State changing and
uh so that's my null test and I'll show
you in a second what the null test
showed and was that the musical content
did not change if you want to climb to
the noise level went down right that's a
different story but let's continue with
the test here on to prove his point that
now you can't null test excuse me he
goes in his room and points a microphone
to the capturing the noises in his room
excuse me and uh he takes a snapshot
freezes it in green and then it runs
another one for use it in white and he
says look if I subtract one from the
other noise wouldn't be reduced well
first he doesn't do the subtraction it's
like you're going to do a notice do an
out that shows that the subtraction
didn't do anything if he had done it he
actually would have noticed that it will
actually do some noise reduction why
does it do noise reduction because if
you look at in here first the spectrum
of noise is not flat it raises in low
frequencies and it goes down to higher
frequencies that's because low
frequencies can't be blocked easily
they're on the directional on the travel
far they go through walls and floors and
so forth and uh unlike electronic noise
which tends to be quite random and quite
wide spectrum oops
uh on this thing so
um and uh the more important thing is
that if you actually look in here you
see specific events happening in here
it's not a random thing this spike is
there in both instances uh on this thing
the reason for that is that we call this
correlated noise a lot of noise like
this is coming maybe from a compressor
for an air conditioner that's traveling
through and that motor's spinning at
certain frequency it actually generates
what we think is noise but when you
analyze it with a spectrum you actually
see that discuss the pattern to it uh
that has to do with the motor design and
everything and uh you know and that's
what noise canceling headphones search
for and and uh reduce the level and
that's what noise canceling headphone
works it takes advantage of correlation
and noise and reduces it by his uh claim
noise canceling headphones wouldn't work
because you can't reduce noise and
indeed that's what noise cancer
headphones do they detect a pattern and
make an inverse signal and subtract it
and and you get a noise reduction in
there so the whole little test in here
was bogus it was like you know smoking
mirrors designed to say I know something
about something but completely wrong
domain you don't use acoustic noises
example of noise cancellation where
noise cancellation does work you want to
use electronic products go ahead and
test the audio product with the two
cables and then show us the Spectrum
difference in noise you climb noise is
reduced okay plug in the two cables if
you have instrumentation show us the
noise before and after and and then
we'll be convinced look at my now tests
on this Vivaldi track and look at the
difference between the two it's pure
noise at extremely low levels over here
and this is well below uh 16 bits you
know you can see 93.5 DB no and it's
just Pure Noise if you click on these
things you won't even hear it unless you
have a very high gain preamp this proves
that you can't there's nothing that's
happened in the music itself and this is
what you kind of test you run if you're
going to climb sound stages change and
all these other benefits you got to do a
proper test and this is a proper test of
a b of two cables it is not an AB of a
microphone noise before and after in his
room which has nothing to do with
anything
okay he then goes into this whole you
know patting himself on his back you
need to have the right system to hear
this and like mine uh where you have
expensive speakers or moved away from
the walls and all this stuff I'm like
well if those are the requirements why
don't you put that in the brochure or
website saying that hey you don't have
this kind of system don't buy this uh if
you're not using my speakers don't buy
them if you're not going to put them
away from the walls don't buy it none of
that is in there and these people claim
to plug it into any old system any
crappy system or good about it different
and they'll hear differences so
therefore his claim that you need these
systems is wrong or these people are
wrong that they say they hear a
difference and then he makes fun of me
using uh headphones to hear differences
well I needed to use headphones because
I wanted to hear that noise that I just
showed you in here and it's extremely
low level to hear that noise you put a
sealed headphone on your head and then
use a headphone amp with a lot of gain
that is extremely low noise itself and
then then you crank it up and what I
hear is just exactly you know what I
described which is just background noise
is extremely low level that is
definitely not all about normal levels
uh he claims headphones are no good it's
like well you know you haven't read a
single piece of research paper every
lossy audio code like many DSP
algorithms even Acoustics researchers
done with headphones because they block
the noise let you put and listen at much
higher level and get sort of inclusively
crosstalk so each headphone you know
brings one signal to each year on this
thing no it's not good to detect there's
a Sound Stage difference or whatever in
a classical sense you use speakers for
that but for that I'll use an altest and
I showed that a musical signal had not
changed on this thing okay
then he uh jumps on the fact that I did
show that there's uh less noise being
induced into the cable and the way I
induce cable is that I took a giant
Transformer uh that comes with my uh
stack uh with my petrol measurement
system and I got that aligned perfectly
right next to the cable and then I
measured the cable as an interconnect so
it was hooked up to the input and output
of my audio Precision analyzer and then
I compared his cable against this
generic thing cable that I was doing and
indeed his cable picks up less noise
from that Transformer that's generating
this huge magnetic field right next to
it worst case situation and I show the
difference so yes there's something to
the geometry of that cable versus
another versus the generic one that
picks up less noise but we gotta put
that in context and in context here is
the screen graph which you didn't
understand or ignored which is showing
the threshold of hearing in here
relative to the playback level of your
system and when I do that the noise from
all of these cables if used as an
interconnect which we don't use an AC
cables and they're gonna it's well below
threshold of audibility so both power
cables actually fully transparent if
they use if you change the termination
and use them as as a interconnect there
still would be totally silent uh on this
thing so and that's why we don't hear
this kind of thing routinely right they
don't you know if people build good
systems they don't walk around bragging
about how great their system is but oh
by the way I hear all this humming noise
it's like no you're not hearing that
because our hearing threshold is very
poor and Ned and by the way you know let
me go back to his thing all this noise
how come he you know he doesn't hear him
right this is his room and look at how
much the low frequency noise it has that
goes way into uh 60 hertz the domain
that I was measuring and this is silent
to his ear because our hearing sucks in
this region uh on that thing okay
so that's that so yes there's the
configuration whatever weave he used
created some kind of twisted pair thing
um so it has a little bit of immunity
extra immunity it still picked up Noise
by the way is this blue here versus the
red so it wasn't like it didn't pick up
anything
um
then he this notion of noise gets
repeated over and over and over again
that these cable is reducing noise
either reducing noise being fed into the
power supply he claims that the cable is
acting as a filter if the cables as a
filter just measures frequency response
if I design a low pass or high pass
filter it shows that just hook it up to
a AC Mains and measure that or
artificial segment show that or just
show ambient noise I've measured
um you know the hopping a90s output and
I show that it makes no difference
whatsoever with his cable versus another
cable why because even when I use
products that do filter they income in
noise I see Zero difference on an output
of audio device why because the first
thing an audio device does a Converse AC
to DC and that processor converting to
DC which means it never changes and
requires filtering and filtering at 10
20 30 volts whatever audio copen
requires is far far far easier than
filtering 120 volts or 240 volts and at
any rate there is no filtering mechanism
here whatsoever there's nothing in there
then this cable has no Active Components
in it no passive components it's just
wire wire doesn't do any filtering it
just carries the current on on AC okay
then the other claim this is you know
favorite of many so improvements can't
be measured uh first let's start with
you know hey it wasn't that convenient
that you say can't be measured therefore
you start off with oh you can't ever
disprove that my cable does anything
um interesting enough Danny main
business is taking people's speakers and
building crossover mods for it and I
shouldn't say main business some of his
business is there and but he never
listens to it he says look here's a
measurement before and his measurement
after you all go build this mod just
going to make your speaker sound better
really I mean what if it doesn't what if
it screwed up the directivity what if it
increased Distortion uh you don't listen
you don't need to listen you trust
measurements so implicitly so strongly
but when it comes to measuring noise in
a cable all of a sudden your
measurements are no good I just showed
you noise measurement it's just trivial
to measure noise and if you can't
measure noise then get out of noise
reduction business uh on this thing so
he says you know obviously you know we
veils are removed and all this stuff
it's like great veils are on all that
removed and should be trivial to do that
testing and prove first that there is an
audible difference if there's an audible
difference when bias has been removed
knowledge of which cable is being used
removed and statistically significant
then we can go back and find a
measurement to to see if the
measurements work so it doesn't work and
until then my null test wins because you
know it shows conclusively that there's
nothing there
um
so we go back to this thing again of
audible differences exists and review
must be wrong it's like great you're
selling me water as you know that you
say you put you know gas tank in a car
makes it Go twice as fast and I say
approve that you say well no I'm just
going to say it and if you found out
that that didn't work then it's your
problem it's like no it's not my problem
you have to first show me the audible
difference reliably exists and if you
can't do that then it's no good and by
the way the test to do that is not to
keep saying I'm here you come over and
listen I'm not going to go to your place
and listen it's your job to run this
business and if you want to run a
business properly show proof points that
your your products do something and the
right solution to that isn't to say I
hear it with my own double-blind test
that we can't verify bring a group of
people audio files I'm sure he has local
audio files that even people who risk
customers bring them in bring half a
dozen people in and then run around by a
set of trials in there at least 10 times
and see if nine out of 10 times these
people can even detect which cables in
use no I don't trust him running a test
like that or somebody else going in
there have been doing there's so many
ways to have a talent these kinds of
tests where you can listen for the sound
or something or something moving or
whoever's running it is not careful
enough and leaves a way for the person
like him that's sharp and smart and is
looking for every opportunity to say
there's a difference to to find a towel
in there and so let's just remove all
that and just have you know audio files
out there with Golden Ears or otherwise
bring them in but run a completely blind
test control test and repeat it many
times don't just do it once or twice and
start with that no uh cable company in
the world has ever run this kind of test
simple enough how long does it take it
takes less time to do this than to make
that 40 minute video uh bring people in
you know and just run these things have
them have a scorecard where they write
down which cables which and just do 10
times you know two or three minutes each
40 minutes you're done show that proof
to us don't make 40 minute videos just
you know talking about stuff that
doesn't exist
okay
um he then makes a claim that you can't
run double blind tests because the
person switching the cables knows that
he's switching the cables to me it's
just fine okay we'll make an exception
for you
um make sure whoever's doing that cable
switching is not an audio file is not
involved in any of this claims you get a
random person off the street come in
maybe somebody works in your Warehouse
or whatever and he does we tell them
what to do and how he's supposed to do
it so that is behind the curtain and you
know nobody can tell and I trust that as
a first order approximation of the
testing that we want to do we could of
course use a relay based switching and
but I'm sure he's going to say the relay
changes the sound so really it's not
good and at any rate It's Tricky relays
make a different sound when they close
ones versus when they open so if you're
smart you can actually listen for that
so yeah just use a person to switch
cables and you know get it done that's
the video I like to see him do not this
kind of video
so to summarize this and keeping my
video shorter than this uh the testing I
did was extremely comprehensive he
covered both measurements and also the
sound with music with three tracks with
with the tracks actually provided to
people to perform control double blind
tests you know he said oh people listen
to my difference the two sample files
and say they sounded different yeah I'm
sure you you I actually said that in the
review that some people listen to A and
B and say they sound different but put
them behind a double blind comparator
and then run 10 times let's see if you
can still hear the difference that's
what he didn't do that's what those
listeners have not done
um and uh you know I started with null
test a whole bunch of his comments on
his video people back and I'm saying oh
measurements are good measurements are
no good okay well I'll run anal test it
wasn't based on measurements
measurements were you know supporting
casts on this thing there are no proof
points in the 40 minutes whatsoever
there's just nothing there from the
company to pack anything uh typically
when I do these tests proper companies
replicate the measurements replicated
testing and bring a different set of
test results when they do then I'll work
with them find out if I made a mistake
they made a mistake here's just making
up stuff of how about this how about
that see what sticks on this thing no
measurements are provided to counter
mine no null tests are provided
whatsoever and key thing is this every
time somebody talks to you about this
and that technical
topic about cables power cables or power
products remind them look my coupon is
not amplifying AC
is converted to DC as a means to make
Electronics do what they do employ if
you get a crappy audio product that lets
noise in for some reason this power
cable isn't going to help you because it
does no filtering whatsoever of anything
coming in and you know if it did you're
going to spend 400 to improve some
crappy piece of electronics
Chuck the crappy piece of electronics
buy hundreds of products that I
recommend that are not crappy and don't
need any special cable in to perform
what they do and by the way none of my
expensive instruments come with any kind
of fancy cables or benefit from this
cable you think audio Precision with 28
000 instrument couldn't afford to put a
hundred dollar Cable in there to make
things better if it reduced noise or
just key metric for an analyzer they
will so and then finally let's say all
these arguments are true this cable is
crap excuse my friend says crap you
can't plug it in it destroys your
Outlets it can be unsafe it is not
doesn't have safety regulations I don't
care what else it does it is not a
proper cable to use
okay hopefully this was part of titanium
somewhat useful for you I really wanted
to do more technical topics reviews but
here I am okay see you in a future video
bye-bye